[Music]
what
yeah ken can make a beat out of this no
we're making oh
nevermind okay we're making it harder
for him
i'm trying to be offbeat anyway okay
we're getting what are we talking about
we are talking about
galen maxwell
joe let her have a trial first why is it
trying like a [ __ ] year or something
i have no [ __ ] oh [ __ ] is this
fabulous they're rich bro
what does that mean [ __ ] up broken fan
that's delane maxwell
we're a million dollar company dude and
we have a [ __ ] up
whose fan is this in the first place
yours
no i've never seen this thing you've
grown where did you get it from
it's been here when i showed up where
i found it there what it's hair fun
all right let me tell you something
there was a leak in the other office
and when i showed up this fan was in my
office i think michael probably used it
to dry it up
oh maybe michael brought it but i never
seen this fan ever in the history of jk
maybe that's why it's michael's if i
click this for a glenn
maxwell article are you clicking away
what the [ __ ]
is this [ __ ] dude i'm two minutes into
this [ __ ]
can you tell me about glenn maxwell
please i hate that [ __ ]
we have new viewers in this channel
anyway okay
what the hell's happening all right so
glenn she
some of her
have been linked no no joe be hot just
be hot [ __ ] trying to turn this off
dude
sorry okay gellane maxwell yes
well have you guys heard of
uh virginia
yeah gear or yeah is that a friend
is that is that one of her close friends
so she was no she was a victim
okay she was like oh the one that ran
away to uh australia right here's galen
jeffrey epstein who
killed himself okay so
this is oh oh oh oh no so
george clooney is in the way i mean in
the in the story george clooney's in
this story because
virginia which is this girl you [ __ ]
her too and then
percent prince andrew is in this photo
and then galen's here okay so
she's the one like the the one accusing
and she actually wrote
a book like a memoir type of thing yup i
remember that yeah and in it
she describes how galain
was just so giddy as a school girl after
she came back from giving george clooney
a [ __ ] at the bathroom at some random
event and that's what we're talking
about
is the fact that glenn she sucked george
clooney suck george clooney i mean
lucky who wouldn't be giddy about that
[ __ ] you good luck here
i don't know you know what else i read
and this one's like more like a gossip
rumor thing not
fully confirmed or whatever but the
rumor is
that george clooney cheated on his wife
amal
with gelane no [ __ ] out of all the women
why did he go for such a low quality one
right and also she's very powerful no i
was gonna say also
does head count no that's cheating yeah
i mean you're telling me it doesn't
count andre 3 000
on the love below he was talking to god
and he was like
hey god head doesn't count right and he
was like oh thanks god
so that means god and andre 2000 said he
doesn't know so chia could get
sucked off no licked off
we're not having any outside ahead in
our relationship i thought it wasn't
cheating tim
i just i asked a question tiff well tim
[Laughter]
back to you back to you
back to you uh in the studio so his head
oh god just look at joe's hairstyle and
that's what's happening in this video
but wait so guy lane guy lane sucked
george clooney lovely
and that that's what this is about
pretty much not about like the deepest
[ __ ] thing going on right now
tell me tell me tell me at all well
there's so much to it but
it and it's crazy it's like i mean is
she even gonna live apparently right now
the justice department is
is moving around between prisons because
they're afraid of what happened before
which means the justice department isn't
even secure with their own procedures
and their own
and it's not until 2021 that her actual
trial begins oh [ __ ] really waiting so
long
there's more chances of getting killed
off well that's why we're waiting
probably conspiracy theory is because
they probably want the same because
powerful pretty normal that uh you don't
go to trial for like
a year or two because you the lawyers
got a prep and all that so like if it
doesn't
you know you could get apprehended you
could be you could spend time in jail
before you even see the court yes but
what about a high-profile case for
someone who just killed off
oj was a another profile okay took a
while same [ __ ] that's right but
what's key to this is that jeffrey
episode died and his victims didn't get
justice because jeffrey epstein died
right
and and we also don't know all the
untold people on the list we know like a
lot of the hot names
but we don't know all the people from
the list and so
is galen going to give up those names
had she already we don't know any of
this [ __ ] yep
the judge released the names on the
black book i saw i mean with the black
book
jeffrey epstein's black book it's so
crazy not the flight logs or no
so there's a there's a whole bunch of
documentation
about all that stuff and it got leaked
with
um did you see all the blacked out stuff
no so there's pages i downloaded
all of it by the way nice there's pages
that were all blacked out right but if
you copy
and paste they did it such a [ __ ] job
the government did such a [ __ ]
way if you copy and paste over the black
you paste it into a notes
uh folder oh everything that was blacked
out shows up
yeah i have it all you see i have all of
it
did they do it on ms paint right dude
but that's what's wild about this right
so i um what what
what was under the black stuff mostly is
actually just kind of boring
frankly from what i saw i didn't get to
go through the whole to you
well no it's like george clooney penis i
wish
dude that's what you're looking for
though you're like did bill clinton go
to the island all this [ __ ]
yeah obviously he's in the logs of is
apparently being on the plane going to
the island but we don't
all the stuff that i wanted to be in
there wasn't necessarily in uh
like what did you want to be in there i
mean how names
how blatant can you be though wasn't his
island called
pedo island or what or is that a name
that or lolita express was the name of
this plane
how that's a porn search when you type
in lolita you're looking for
teams isn't that the one it's the book
whatever lol
is it lola wants lola gets is it lolita
that story that movie
it's a book and then uh and then it got
turned into a bunch of [ __ ]
yeah but it's about this young girl
right that she ends up
getting in like sex with an older man
involved with her stuff and the kubrick
movie
but there is a thing there's also a
thing called grooming right so so
a lot of what you're talking about too
is about making some of this stuff okay
so that when um it's actually happening
in real life it's more fetishized and
fantasized about
than you're actually looking at the
reality of it and so i don't know if you
guys saw this
like yesterday or something this troll
dog um we talked about it yesterday
yesterday oh man it's [ __ ] wild to
see yeah yeah if you don't know it
i i saw the twitter video it's not on
the packaging the buttons on the vagina
area or the butthole area and
the sounds it makes it's like that
leaves people to have a lot of questions
so i you know the virginia roberts and
then like a lot of the
ladies who were trafficked by yeah
that's right
uh australian news did a really [ __ ]
good
like interview on all of them and a lot
of them are kind of seeking refuge in
australia and other countries because
they're afraid of like
america and what they're saying is like
okay this is how powerful they are like
people are still afraid of epstein after
his death
think about it like there's so many
people involved
epstein epstein had to be afraid for his
own death like you know i feel like
epstein was just a fall man exactly
like he wasn't even like that even
important probably
and the theory behind it is galen's
dad is the real beginner he's a media
guy right
right yeah so his history is he is
um i think a ukrainian jewish man or
whatever right and then
uh during world war ii he is a a war
hero
because i guess he fought for the
british side he immigrated there
so so all this stuff and then afterwards
um he wanted to find his
family members which was a part of the
ussr
so he had to infiltrate like go back to
his old country
and then he became a double agent of
like the british spy agency as well as
irani or or israeli mossad and then
uh the kgb so he was like a triple agent
or whatever
and he was he had a whole life of spying
right
and then so he became a media mogul he
he became this [ __ ] baller
rumor has it that he got funding and all
this stuff
from mossad which is the the the the cia
of israel right he made all this [ __ ]
money
like israel he was originally from
czechoslovakia oh czech not ukraine yeah
yeah well
he's jewish so that's how his connection
is to israel
but then he was a jewish minority that
grew up in czechoslovakia
czechoslovakia during that time was ussr
which is the soviet union
yeah and then so this was all during
that era right but he
he he he's he's a media mogul in uh
the uk yes british media yeah galen grew
up
in mad wealth all this stuff rumor has
it that he was molesting her
all this weird [ __ ] wait so incest i
believe it
yeah yeah yeah so so he really liked
epstein
right and then um he wanted to hook up
his daughter with epstein
he wanted he saw him as like a future
future son-in-law right epstein at the
time was like some
high school teacher he wasn't like some
uh uh
banker or anything and no one knows
where the [ __ ] his wealth came from
but the rumor is glenn's dad
which was the media mogul and ran all by
the mossad
uh agency he [ __ ] over
his editorial which was like the red sun
or something like that
there was a huge scandal where he used
everyone's pension money
and just blew it off right and so the
the scotland yard or whatever they were
investigating him and then they were
gonna put him in trial and then he
killed himself what right so the same
way epstein went out
so [ __ ] weird if you know the
backstory so glenn till this day has
said
my dad was murdered he did not [ __ ]
kill himself
one went out on a yacht and then they
took him out
so now what they're saying is it's
interesting because after that
all of a sudden epstein started becoming
this invested investment banker baller
all this stuff
he has all the [ __ ] money yeah rumor
has it though
that no one no no ever heard of this
fool in the in the
hedge fund world and it's a small world
like everyone knows each other in that
area especially if you're moving
billions of dollars right yeah they're
all saying that epson doesn't even act
like he
no it comes from money either yeah
they're like weird they're like
it's like great gatsby right like he's
he's faking the funk they're saying that
epstein acts like he's an eight-figure
guy and they're like there's a
difference between a eight-figure guy
and a nine-figure guy nine figure guys
or like like billionaires or whatever
they have different levels he goes how
is this eight figure guy
acting like a nine figure guy right the
whole history between the two
is basically the rumor is
galen is his handler like in the spy
world whatever you have someone who's
controlling you right
so glenn her funding all this stuff her
dad's money all this stuff
um is funding epstein's
whole racket of controlling powerful
people
of getting them recorded doing criminal
acts of pedophilia
then he can control presidents he can
control all this stuff damn and it's all
linked to the spy agency massage yeah
and that's the
the idea is that that's where they get
the money that's where they get the
money because mossad has
lots and lots of that's israel israel
yes it's their intel agency
and it's not uh it's not far-fetched
because the cia has done it in the
middle east we had a playboy out there i
forgot his name
and in the contras yeah he had a big uh
uh mansion
where he would get uh saudi arabians or
all kinds of middle east dudes like
you know having sexual intercourse with
and videotaping them and then they would
blackmail them
so it's like a huge honeypot operation
same deal with
epstein there this is where it's all
leading to is we have a lot of
powerful people scientists politicians
uh ceos we have so much judges so much
dirt
it involves so many people that nobody
wants this to get out
and one of these journalists that went
through all of this said that
the reason why we're not covering this
is because there's so many people
involved from the
left the right like you had the clintons
and all that you might have trump
involved royalty
you have royalty prince andrew you have
media moguls
on both sides you have and so nobody
wants to touch it
because it does it get it doesn't get
covered
but australian media though there's no
one really caught in this mix
so they're just interviewing all these
ladies they're doing
it's pretty nuts yeah it's pretty good
yeah so i went down the rabbit hole i
gotta catch up on it but
there's a lot of [ __ ] good
information on this crazy
[Music]
you